>> My name is James Kondo, I'm President of
Health Policy Institute from
Japan.
I think that India is already in Asia and
destined to be a superpower.
I think one of the things that is most exciting
about what is the
diversity, but also the demographic that's
just different, for example,
from China, which is aging almost as much
as Japan, my own country, is.
There's going to be a tremendous, I think,
demographic dividend for
India as the number of youth segment will
likely be the largest middle
market in the world, really creating a lot
of services for the middle
class, but, I believe, experimental ground
for creating a new actions
for the population in the world rolled out.
I do think that India is destined to be a
superpower.
Thank you.